hi there this is steve here i'm now in
palm springs
um
you probably think i do an awful lot of
traveling
which is true
but then again i worked pretty hard for
almost 50 years and i'm not retired so i
can travel
today i want to talk about
motivation
versus interesting or compelling content
now remember if you enjoy these videos
please subscribe by the way i'm not
trying to pretend that i'm incognito
here but the sun is rather bright in my
eyes so i'm wearing these sunglasses so
what triggered this was a post by
stephen grashan stephen krashen whom i
greatly admire
as the clearest and most
i would say to the point explainer of
language acquisition
and he says that motivation is finished
as a factor in language
education
and he would like to replace that with
the idea of interesting or compelling
content
so this caused me to think and i it
caused me to look at my own learning
situation now of course i'm not typical
so the first thing that we have to look
at
in sort of factors that affect success
in language learning is
is the fact that people are all
different
so i am
naturally motivated to learn i want to
learn greek why
just because i visited crete for two
weeks
of course
having assigned myself the task of
learning greek
um
past now my two week or it wasn't really
it was like a 12-day visit to crete i'm
still motivated to learn more and more
because i'm discovering so much about
the culture and i enjoy
being able to read being able to listen
being able to understand being able to
communicate in
greek so i am not typical
the other end of the spectrum
is the classroom where typically most of
the students are not motivated
so i think in the classroom situation
stephen krashen is absolutely right you
cannot browbeat these people the
students by telling them that you need
the language because one day you might
have a career or because you can
discover wonderful cultures none of this
is going to have any impact so for the
student in the classroom
in a high school
you have to give them something that's
compelling some story some movie
something that will you know spark their
interest
however in my case and in the case of
many adults who want to learn a given
language they are motivated so now what
you have to do
is in my view you have to have a sort of
a combination of intrinsically
interesting content
plus some other content that is
beneficial
you know to the learning process but
perhaps not that interesting so in the
case of greek i vary
between
a sort of
interesting content about greek history
about some books while i was in greek on
in greece rather on history and
other content that i know is good for me
like these repetitive mini stories where
i know because the
stories contain a lot of
very common verbs because the vocabulary
repeats so often in each lesson
that i know that repetitive listening to
these stories while it's no longer
interesting is beneficial
uh
similarly i am
dictating these uh texts these are again
call them you know the text part of this
textbook not the grammar exercises or
the um explanations but just that's a
little text that uh in each lesson
there's either one or two of those for
which i have the audio and when i listen
to the audio i don't understand
everything so i'm dictating these so
that i can import them into link this is
not compelling content but it is useful
it is effective learning material
and so
i guess the point i want to make is that
whether you are
you know
driven by motivation
or whether there is an absence of
motivation as is the case in classrooms
uh that will determine what kind of
content is suitable for you
so if you are a relatively unmotivated
person in a classroom or if you are a
teacher teaching these relatively
unmotivated kids you have to find
something that is compelling or
interesting that drives them
to learn the language
if you are an independent learner and
actually quite motivated you still need
to have this interesting and compelling
content because after a while even a
motivated person gets bored dealing with
uninteresting content so i in all of my
language learning i've sought out
interesting content whether it be on the
internet ebooks whatever it might be
but at the same time i do spend
some portion of my time and it'll vary
depending on my mood with essentially
not that interesting content but content
because of which because of the the the
fact that it's repetitive or because i
like the voice of the narrator or
whatever it might be this is content
that my motivation
uh and of course typically this is
content that i will use at an early
stage of learning the language where i
have difficulty accessing more
compelling content
that this kind of content can be very
effective and so ultimately
if you are an independent learner you
get to choose what you want to use as
content you can vary it harder easier
compelling less compelling
whatever your motives are you get to
choose what you learn
in the classroom typically it's the
teacher who decides what the content is
going to be or at least provides
hopefully some choice to the learners
and in that case
i agree with stephen krashen that the
the key there is not necessarily
motivation which might be a futile hope
in the case of many classroom learners
but rather it's a matter of directing
them or guiding those students towards
something that might be interesting to
them and therefore becomes compelling
and therefore drives them to learn the
language and get interested in the
language so just a little chat about the
issue of interest versus motivation
compelling content versus useful content
both in terms of my experience and what
i presume is the experience of a
classroom teacher
thank you for listening bye for now
[Music]
you